I'm now delighted to introduce our
speaker today Mr Eddie Wu
Eddie teaches mathematics at Cherry
Brook technology high school
he is a leader
of mathematics growth for New South
Wales Department of Education and works
as the education Ambassador for the
University of Sydney
for the last 10 years he has uploaded
his everyday classroom lessons to his
YouTube channel YouTube
which has more than 1.5 million
subscribers and 130 million views
Eddie is an alumnus of the University he
obtained his Bachelor of Education with
honors in 2007 and received the
University of Sydney outstanding
achievements for young alumni award in
2017.
in 2018 he was named Australia's Local
Hero
in the Australian of the Year Awards and
listed as one of the top 10 teachers in
the world by the global teacher prize
he is an internationally published
author TV host Ted speaker and fellow of
the Royal Society of New South Wales
Mr Eddie Wu it gives me great pleasure
to welcome you back to the university
and I invite you to deliver the
occasional address
[Applause]
Deputy Chancellor for insane
Professor Hayes staff distinguished
guests all of whom are so important but
who are really here to recognize the
importance of you the graduates your
friends and family on this special and
momentous day
I too would like to acknowledge the
traditional custodians of the land the
gadigal people of the aura Nation
because walking into these Majestic
University grounds for the first time in
2004 to begin my studies it was clear
that I was entering a place that had a
long tradition of learning in community
that's why I pay my respect to Elders
past present and emerging and extend
that respect to all First Nations people
here with us today
it's enormous privilege for me to
address you and there are two things I
want to impress upon you in the short
time that I have to speak with you
first I'd like to help you see your
truly unique position in history and in
our society
and second I'd like to guide you on how
you can use that position
every graduate in this room is a bridge
builder
I know some of you may be thinking I
wanted into the civic engineering
graduation ceremony by mistake but hear
me out
whether education social work or
languages and cultures each of you is
Building Bridges
some of you are building them between
childhood and adulthood
others are building them between diverse
peoples and their perspectives on the
world
all of us have studied and labored so
that we might know how to stand Between
Worlds and knit them together through
ideas relationships and dialogue
this is Noble important and essential
work
our planet despite being globalized
through intertwining Technologies and
economies is more polarized than ever
our planet is marked in so many places
by Discord misunderstanding and conflict
our planet is brimming with young people
who are looking for a sense of
meaningful identity and moral purpose
but floating in an ocean of competing
voices from family friends societal
structures and social media those young
people are often Unsure how to find that
identity and purpose
our planet needs Bridges
big ones between nations and small ones
between Neighbors
in the 15 years that I've been a teacher
I have loved building those bridges
I love connecting students with new
knowledge
I love connecting young people with
passions and interests they didn't know
they'd have and Leadership opportunities
they didn't believe they were capable of
I love connecting parents with a
different perspective of their own
children that they haven't been able to
see in all the bustle of trying to raise
a family
but it's hard work
full of challenges and it's been
especially difficult over these last
three years as every profession has been
doing we've all been trying to find ways
new ways to live and work in this Global
pandemic on the one hand you have people
like me busily devising solutions for
how to function effectively through
shifting Health guidelines and how to
make plans while maintaining a loose
grip on those plans
and on the other hand there are people
like my students who've been on the
receiving end of all that passengers on
a flight where we've been building the
plane as we fly it
many of us had less than two weeks to
work out the nuts and bolts of how to
provide online learning and how to
provide services remotely that run on a
completely different Dynamic than when
they are face to face
but this is where your uniqueness comes
in
you see when it comes to people Building
Solutions and people receiving those
Solutions you are uniquely both those
groups of people
as you enter into life Post University
you will be at the Forefront of
Designing and delivering new systems for
how we live and work in this Brave New
World
and you know what it's like to live
firsthand through that turmoil you
intimately understand the benefits and
challenges of making life work in this
context in a way that I never will
you inhabit Both Worlds by virtue of
your lived experience
I said before that you all are bridge
Builders but in fact through your unique
experiences you are the bridges
so
how will you use that unique position
it's been said that the two most
important days of your life are the day
you were born
and the day you find out why
for me that second day happened here at
the University I originally set out to
become an English and history teacher
because those are the subjects that I
excelled at during school
but when I was enrolling I encountered a
professor who explained to me that there
was and remains an acute shortage of
mathematics Educators in New South Wales
and indeed across the country and most
of the western world
that day I changed my enrollment and it
sent me on an adventure that has enabled
me to achieve things I never dreamed of
and has in turn led me to stand here
before you today
now people sometimes ask me why I was so
willing to make such a snap decision to
dramatically change the course of my
life
but for me it wasn't a snap decision
you see like many of you I'm the child
of migrants who moved to this country at
Great personal cost to open up
opportunities for their children
and this is part of why I deeply feel
the Grateful burden of responsibility to
take the educational riches I have
received and use them to serve others if
the place where my service would be most
valuable was in Mass education then
actually it made intuitive sense for me
to move in that direction
and the truth is no matter how long you
have been here whether it's measured in
years Generations or millennia
everyone everyone here in this room is a
recipient of a marvelous treasure
that treasure is The Learning Journey
that you have taken through this
University which has made you a
different person to the one who first
entered this campus it's made you a
better person
now there are two approaches for how you
can use this treasure one we can use
that treasure merely for our own
advancement
or two we can use it to improve the
lives of the communities around us and
around the world now this first approach
will gratify you for a Time
but the second approach will help you
create a legacy that is bigger than you
that will Outlast you and will create
opportunities in the future for more
people just like you
the reason I've been able to do the
things I've done is because I've always
searched for ways to enrich others with
the treasure that I've received and I
hope you do the same
congratulations on all you've received
you've come an incredible distance and
overcome immense obstacles to be here
but now the real adventure begins
go and build Bridges through the work
you do
go and be bridges of using all the
knowledge and qualities that you've
developed here at the University
go and do it all in ways and places that
enrich everyone you interact with
thank you
[Applause]